بالنسبه للاقبال على المدرسه فامتلقت
المقاعد الصفيه ما يقارب 80% طبعا نحن ما
ياسنا ولسه عم ندور على حالات خارج المركز
في كثير من اولياء الامور ما عم باقبله
على تسجيل ابنه للمدارس في عندهم فكره انه
طفل هو معاقد جسد توجه للرساله انه
الاعاقه هي بالعقل ما هي بالجلساته ونحن
مستمرين بالتسجيل لاخر يوم بالمدرسه
الاهالي اللي اطفالهم اقمله لهاي المدرسه
كانت تعليقاتهم ايجابيه جدا هي اعطتنا
القوه هي اعطتنا الاستمرار اعطتهم الامل
كمان انه طفلهم رجع مثل ما كامل
ما في تمويل حقيقي للمدرسه طبعا للمدرسه
اعشقتها بجهود شخصي لساده عم بشتغل بشكل
تطوعي السنه اللي يخليني استمر او تعوي
حاجه طفل لهذا المكان لهاي المدرسه ومحبته
هدفه اني اخلاق منه شيء قوي
[موسيقى]